ces images de la télé chinoise montrent
semblant de retour à la normale dans les
grandes villes mais il y a clairement
moins d'achalandage sur les routes dans
les marchés et les centres commerciaux
dit-il mais les investissements
permettent de maintenir 62% des
activités dans le secteur de la
construction mais la majorité des usines
et des commerces tourneront ralentis des
millions de Chinois sont sans emploi
Paris cadets dans leur petit logement
pendant des semaines
dans cette vidéo qui n'est pas
authentifiée en résidant se fait emmener
de force dans un centre de traitement
probablement parce qu'il ne s'est pas
fait tester ce jour-là il n'a pas de
résultats négatif à montrer
de contrôle des infections affirme que
la colère exprimait lors des
protestations cible
la plupart une rare reconnaissance
officielle du ras-le-bol des Chinois que
la répression massive déployée depuis le
week-end ne réussit pas à étouffer
est-ce que des forces étrangères vous
ont dit de venir ici non répond la foule
d'étudiants rassemblés à Pékin lundi
soir le gouvernement chinois accuse des
puissances étrangères d'être à l'origine
des troubles
de quelle force étrangères parlez-vous
scandin étudiant de Marx Engels Staline
Lénine je tiens à dire que j'aime mon
pays le problème ce sont les politiques
actuelles
le régime chinois réagit aux pression de
la rue il est désormais interdit de
mettre des cadenas aux portes pour
empêcher les gens de sortir et on va
intensifier avec 6 nations des personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans qui sont encore
peu immunisés
chez les plus de 80 ans seulement 20%
sont pleinement vaccinés et ils
reçoivent des vaccins chinois moins
efficaces que ceux de Pfizer moderna qui
sont interdits en Chine
je ne suis pas vaccinée 17 femmes de 83
ans parce que j'ai déjà une maladie
pulmonaire mais si mon médecin pense que
je dois l'être je me ferai vacciné
17 hommes de 79 ans parce qu'il faut
rouvrir pour relancer l'économie si on
reste confiné l'économie va souffrir
l'explosion des quatre covides ces
dernières semaines semblent inciter
Pékin à opter pour une plus grande
vaccination ce qui réduit les besoins et
de confinement ici ce fil en gloire
Radio-Canada MONT